let's continue implementing the addChoice method. You've already done the first
part, adding a new choice to the list of choices, now if this parameter here
says that it was the correct choice then we should set the answer, and the
answer should be a string 1, 2, 3 or 4 depending on whether this was the first,
second, third or fourth choice. How do you know which choice it was? It's not
passed as a parameter to add choice, but you can tell by looking at how many
elements are already in the choices array. Of course, when you ask the choices
array for it's size, that's an integer, answers are strings, just concatenate
with the empty string to change the integer to a string. And now you're
going to have a bit of a challenge. When you have a choice question object, it
has two instance variables. The correct answer, this instance variable is
inherited from the question super class and the list of choices. You will want
to set the answer to a string, such as this string 3, but how can you get at
it? The answer is an instance variable of the question class and it's private,
no one can access anything private in the question class accept the methods of
the question class themselves. Choice question extends question but that
doesn't give it any special privileges. It cannot access this instance field
any more than anyone else. So that's the challenge you need to overcome. And
the point is, of course, that just like everyone else, you will need to use the
public interface off the question class. Go ahead, give it a try, and implement
the add choice method.